après avoir obtenu une position très
prometteuse avec les blancs dans la
partie d'ouverture du Championnat du
monde sans parvenir à concrétiser pour
autant yannick a frappé très fort en
s'imposant dans la deuxième partie du
match en seulement 29 coups avec les
pièces noires c'est rare ici à ce niveau
vous savez pourtant bien commencé pour
diminueren qui a des concocté en
laboratoire à une nouvelle idée dans
l'ouverture alors qu'on se diriger vers
une classique catalane le numéro en
chinois a joué le 13 inattendu coup de
pion H3 défiant les fondamentaux des
ouvertures se développaient et prendre
le centre des pots n’a pas masqué sa
surprise à la caméra et après avoir pris
le temps de se rafraîchir les idées il a
décidé d'emmener son rival sur le
terrain toujours glissant des rock
opposés où il est parvenu à monter une
attaque foudroyante pour conclure la
partie avec panache et prendre les
commandes du duel au sommet dès le
deuxième jour de match